the streets are festooned with
Eurovision banners the fans are getting
into the spirit of the occasion the
Eurovision song contest is in town and
oh boy does Liverpool know it
the competition was won last year by
kalush Orchestra who represented Ukraine
they should have hosted the event this
year Russia's Invasion meant it couldn't
be held in Kiev so the UK offered to
host the event on behalf of Ukraine
fans from across the world have
descended on the host City in the
northwest of England it's a Once in a
Lifetime experience for many mindful of
the reason it's in Liverpool we're from
mid Wales and we've waited decades for
the Eurovision to come here so we can
come and enjoy it on our home soil I
know we're sharing it with Ukraine and
we hope that we all do well everyone's
enjoying the city of Liverpool city is
really buzzing everywhere you go every
step you take it's Eurovision it's
amazing yeah yeah for the first time in
Eurovision history a major cultural
event is running parallel to the contest
reflecting Ukraine's artistic prowess 12
singing inflatable Nightingales the
national Songbird of the country are
perched across the city decorated in
patterns reflecting the regional art of
the country the woman behind the idea
escaped Kiev on the second day of the
conflict I want them to be interested in
Ukraine and see how diverse it is that
we have
different places that capture the world
it would be I want them to visit all
these places this installation called
protect the beat surrounds Nelson's
Monument it illustrates how arts and
culture are under attack up to the end
of April this year the un's cultural
body UNESCO officially recorded over 250
art and cultural sites had been damaged
by conflict in Ukraine the last time
Liverpool hosted a major International
cultural event it was when it was
selected as the European capital of
culture in 2008 and as it was then the
city is a buzz and the symbol of that
historic year here for Liverpool was
this the yellow land banana that's now
been repainted in the colors of the
Ukrainian flag those organizing the
events and installations across
Liverpool are clear why they're doing
this we wanted to create a whole program
that had those emotions in it then also
had
Indian culture and art so that when they
are reopened you know when they're when
they can go home we can visit them and
we'll have that real sense of Ukraine as
the countdown begins all at Liverpool
and Ukraine can say is welcome sit back
and enjoy the Eurovision experience of
being united by music sahil Rahman Al
Jazeera Liverpool
foreign